souvenez vous il ya qu'à jos et de
français ont décidé de tout plaquer pour
prêter main forte aux ukrainiens je suis
européen je vais aider un peuple de
cette tyrannie russe alors que le
président glaudini zelensky appel et
d'européens à leur venir en aide ne
restaient pas sinon son secret c'est le
crâne tombe toute l'europe tanguera
mathieu agents immobiliers fabrice
serveurs tous deux anciens militaires
allaient répondu présent en décidant de
s'engager pour stopper l'invasion russe
en ukraine si je peux apporter ma
formation de jabot au niveau du déminage
là bas je ferai alors au 20e jour de
guerre que deviennent m'a tuer fabrice
images chocs révélations et témoignages
ce soit mathieu et fabrice nous raconte
les horreurs du terrain
merci fabrice merci mathieu d'être avec
nous et merci sergueï mironov ancien
espion du kgb ça va vous étiez un petit
peu souffrant ça va ça va benoît maire
fabrice merci d'être là volontaires
français de retour du cren vous êtes
serveur vous avez servi cinq ans dans la
légion étrangère vous étiez venu nous
voir le 1er mars il ya deux semaines cas
vous vous apprêtiez à partir combattre
en ukraine vous êtes marty qu'entraîneur
je porte une pochette jours plus tard
sept jours plus tard que jobs plutôt
très bien faire au peuple en mars comme
le 8 mars c'est sorti je calcul bien
vous êtes parti comment par vos propres
moyens vers les rejoindre moyens
financiers mon véhicule personnel
adacore pardon vous avez fait vous êtes
parti je suis parti de la seule la
france je suis monté par l'allemagne la
pologne ah ouais j'ai traversé toute la
pologne jusqu'à la frontière et crennel
en voiture en voiture incroyable et vous
êtes arrivé donc là bas vous arrivez en
pologne elle affronterait la frontière
ukrainienne di pasqua bah tout
simplement qu'on a on a du mal à passer
au début un donc voilà je vous dise quoi
vous auriez vous dites quoi on arrive ça
vous n'avez d'humanitaire d'un à
l'intérieur du véhicule on a pu quand
même montrer qu'on peut qu'on passait à
la fois de chéruy craignait que c'est un
peu plus compliqué parce qu'il faut les
papiers quand même d'accord mais ça off
on a réussi à passer assez facilement
d'accord donc là et aussi et on continue
à son passeport et sans passeport
compass mort vont entrer d'accord là
vous est alors pris en charge par un
coordinateur ou ludiques aux
coordinateurs vous mariez vous dites moi
je veux que tu me battre à vos côtés non
en fait c'est un coordinateur qu'on
assure sur un réseau d'accords donc
voilà il nous donne une adresse un point
de rendez-vous on doit se démerder pour
y aller d'accord c'est à dire qu'on doit
y aller par nos propres moyens jusqu'au
bout faites donc ainsi un problème entre
deux lui en a rien à [ __ ] c'est pour
notre pomme d'accord vous allez avoir
donc une petite formation
petite formation s'est vite j'étais
rapide c'est quoi vous arrivé là bas
vous dit pas vous dîtes moi je m'arrête
on arrive là bas on entend que engagé
volontaire je vais employer le terme
engagé volontaire parce que pour moi
c'est meilleur c'est mieux et on arrive
là bas et on est pris en charge que
pendant 40 24 heures donc sur à
l'endroit à un endroit on s'envoie 24
heures plus tard dans un autre endroit
différent et là on nous explique
justement le recrutement d'accord il
faut savoir pour rendre pas non plus
comme ça on n'arrive pas qu'aux coup
c'est moi je vais énorme ou quoi que ce
soir et ça tombe ça marche pas comme ça
donc tous ceux qui veulent partir là-bas
en ukraine surtout ceux qui n'ont pas de
formation militaire restez dans vos
clichés papa maman et fermez vos gueules
fermez vos gueules voilà comme on dit ça
maintient très complices cusin qua non
mais c'est ça qu'il faut le dire avec
des mots durs parce qu'il faut que les
gens comprennent c'est pas on va pas
faire là bas on va pas faire les malins
et dire je vais partir et je vais faire
le beau là bas ce qui ferait qui régala
on le par il ya beaucoup de gens qui
mettent des trucs sur un star etc c'est
pas voilà cccc l'état précis si ce n'est
pas un jeu c'est pas du doigt jeu si on
croirait arrivé là-bas et sur un gros
salaire pareil à salaires voilà que je
vais là-bas je prends des photos j'ai un
salaire je travaille pour eux bas
salaires c'est 500 euros maintenant que
si tu veux y aller pour gagner l'argent
c'est pas la peine si tu allais pour
aller au combat banier part restant à la
maison donc à quoi s'attendre on va pas
directement sur le 100 lignes de front
d'accord alors justement pour aller au
combat pour aller au combat qu'est ce
qui s'est passé parce que vous vouliez
aller combat s'annonçait le 1er mars
nous avait dit que voulait aller
combattre vous arrivé là bas vous dites
que vous voulez combat que vous allez
vous avez fait la légion étrangère on
vous dit quoi bon moment qu'on m'a
demandé ma spécialité on m'a fait passer
le petit le tisseur clos qu'il fallait
faire donc une spiritualité est
magnifique mais qui comprend un mois
c'est l'osso buco cuisine non mais ça
tombait donc oui et donc là vous dites
quoi réalité c'est quoi ce déminage
voilà c'est ce que vous nous aviez dit
me voilà donc là c'est ce que vous
vouliez faire là bas c'est ce que je
voulais faire donner donner une
formation militaire là-bas et ça c'est
pas moi c'est pareil qu'est-ce qui vous
ont mis bas on m'a regardé une fois que
j'ai fini le tour bien sûr on m'a
regardé match et
voilà non alors il faut se demander de
faire quoi bon tout simplement est-ce
que j'ai une paire de lunettes ah oui
c'est ça on m'a refoulé à l'entrée parce
d'accord voilà une fois qu'on m'avait
expliqué j'avais fait le tour pendant un
bon moment tout simplement ce qu'on a
une paire de lunettes alors non c'est
pas bon ou quand vous ai dit quoi paire
de lunettes c'est pas bon pour faire du
déminage bref où on m'a juste fait
montrer la lunette non terminés et
europorte donc vous a demandé vous a
proposé de faire autre chose rien du
tout rien du tout rien du tout il ya
deux jours de soldes ce qu'on peut faire
c'est quoi mais je suis pas suicidaire
epoch times sniper c'est ça et voilà et
le deuxième c'est parra comme on dit
dans le jargon français par recommande
donc ça c'est partir au fond partir au
front directement ça c'est une pareille
que là bas on dit que c'est partir à la
mort rien c'est ça c'est le succès ça
donc c'est qu'est ce qui se passe on
vous dit vous passez par là vous savez
que ces essais vous revenez pas quoi
c'est très peu de chances de revenir
maria pas que forcément important sur le
fond juste un an en tant qu engagés
volontaires ont perdu la vie mais
je suis parti avec un collègue deux
collègues moi j'étais refoulé lui il est
resté
il a pas eu tant de porter une arme pas
eu tant de porter un
équipement
il a eu un bombardement à hier au vif et
bien il est resté sans porter une
il a rien compris il a fait 24 heures 24
heures il est mort là martin
le collègue qui vous un des collègues et
qui vous est parti mais voilà par des
collègues que je pars tu avais plus y'a
pas fils a fait 24 heures est tentée
s'est passé
c'est dur ce que dit fabrice essai c'est
la réalité il faut le savoir voilà c'est
c'est pas un jeu c'est la guerre et
fabrice jeu je sens que vous étiez parti
vous étiez plein d'espoir le 1er mars la
vous revenez vous revenez avec la
réalité de ce qui se passe là bas et
vous dites quand on apprend le décès de
quelqu'un hier soir à 2 heures du matin
sachant qu'on la con et tu ressembles
depuis quelques jours ça fait ça fait
mal quand à bien sûr ça fait très mal
pour moi et c'est moi qui l'emmenait à
la morgue c'est simple si vous qui la
veille avait convaincu de partir s'il
est venu on est parti ensemble donc on a
fait pas mal de choses on s'arrêtait un
petit peu avant quelques jours avant de
partir s'arrêter de manger une dernière
vue une dernière bière un dernier bain
des petits restos ouais
et puis bah voilà il a fait le trajet
avec vous en voiture il a fait le trajet
c'était mon deuxième pilote qui était
avec moi qui conduisais avec moi là on a
volé à deux tours de la route le
troisième n'a pas roulé s'il n'a pas le
permis et donc on a quand même fait
pratiquement 24 heures 24 heures de
route on a dormi dans la voiture le soir
et voilà il lui dit qu'il a été pris il
habitait s'il a été prévu pour faire
quoi lui voulait partir justement sur le
terrain carrément et commandos grammont
à lille voilà donc là aussi qu'il
partait il était parti pour faire
quelques quelques journées c'est au
niveau des armes mais voir ce qui ce
qu'ils veulent exactement les people
appelle-t-on en fait il a été un peu le
temps il est emporté par par le
bombardement
comme vous l'avez appris par téléphone
hier soir c'est commencer c'est pas rien
à un autre collègue et moi qui est à
quai sur place et justement qui est
aussi engagé là bas alors moi ce que je
veux je fais dire tout de suite
maintenant après jessica veut dire
calcul il me le dira mais tous ceux qui
veulent partir là bas ne partez pas pas
de passeport n'y allez pas c'est simple
vous passez plus mais si vous n'êtes pas
d'ancienneté militaire vous passiez pas
ça c'est clair donc ceux qui n'ont pas
de passé militaire qu'ils ont fait du
airsoft qui sont encore sur des consoles
de jeux ou quoi que ce soit resté chez
papa maman est allé dormir paisiblement
regardez la guerre à la télé mais mai
par la voix vous avez vu de nombreuses
guerres comment vous avez vu d'autres
guerres pour vous ce que vous avez vu en
ukraine je crois que vous aviez dit les
équipes qui a aucune règle il n'y a pas
de règle du tout y a pas de règle du
tout tout le monde passe mais les gamins
aussi et j'ai eu pas mal de monde en
compte à qui voulait partir dans mon
convoi que j'ai refusé
et c'est possible qu'en fait vous dites
je l'aï sauvée
malgré le décès de thériault ce matin ça
cette semaine j'ai quand même sauvé deux
personnes trois personnes qui m'ont
contacté leurs fans m'ont contacté par
les réseaux sociaux et qui me demandait
des informations je réalise que
pardonner et les mecs étaient prêts à
partir des anciens légionnaires qui
n'est pas partir samedi bon allez là bas
vous l'aurez vite pas partir je leur ai
expliqué je leur ai montré certaines
choses qu'est-ce que vous l'avez dit
exactement ce qu'on pouvait nous dire ce
que vous leur avez dit parce que on est
on est curieux de savoir avec les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
ce que vous avez dit à ses légionnaires
qui voulaient partir pour les dissuader
peuvent être cruels si je dors si je
vous dis moi pour moi ce que je la relis
je viens cruella cheveux je veux que
vous nous disiez mot pour mot ce que
vous avez dit si jamais tu pars en
ukraine je viens je viens de voir que tu
m'aides lanotte a gun
et m'a demandé pourquoi je leur ai dit
si tu es là la morgue mais c'était petit
gamin des enfants à la maison était
favre est ta femme à la maison vas-y ces
moments et il ya aussi est de savoir ils
ont essayé de savoir plus d'informations
sur les contacts jardiner contact veux
pas en avoir parce que je te donnerai
pas si facile à passer une fois qu'un
contact là bas et il m'a demandé
justement qu'est ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire par la suite s'ils pouvaient faire
d'humanitaire je lui dis tu veux fallu
mater vas-y mais sainté risques et
périls quand même et j'ai contacté aussi
c'est sa femme qui m'ont qu'on a parlé
et j'ai été clair avec elle aussi je lui
dis si ton mari par là bas il va la
morgue il va être carrément est ce moi
j'ai une balle dans la tête et ils m'ont
rappelé une demi-heure plus tard vous
j'ai envoyé des photos entre 2 et m'a
dit ok je pars pas
bien là et pour vous avez sur les
services ovi de vie en fêtant doug
weight j'ai soulevé deux groisne
d'ailleurs fait un petit coucou et
doug il a rendez vous lundi après midi
j'espère qu'il va mettre n'est sa
mission à bien vous dites que les
volontés là bas sont de la chair à canon
c'est à dire que on se dit ah oui quand
vous quand on vous envoie au front c'est
très bien que vous avez très peu de
chances de revenir ça sent quand on
penser qu on si on penser qu'on revient
pas ah ouais on sait qu'on revient pas
et les volontaires au niveau du combat
ils sont envoyés en première ligne
comme si que c'était dans le passé avec
les pays africains qu'on emmenait dans
la guerre et qu'on envoyait en premier
au front pour moi l'image que j'eus la
même chose
si vos lunettes qui vous on se répond
moi c'est me nettoie ses mails y en a
qui m'ont sauvé quand même parce que le
bombardement a eu lieu à peine 24 heures
après que soit leur parti ce soir il
restait que votre collègue je vais
rester avec lui ce qui était prévu à la
base et imaginant qu'il repartait pas pu
être faire tu procurer à vérifier donc
par ailleurs par la maison et tu fais ce
que tu as à faire
des couteaux
qu'est ce que vous avez vu la voie que
vous n'aviez pas vu dans d'autres
guerres
le malheur des gens à lviv les réfugiés
l'aide qui n'est pas forcément présente
sur lviv non plus
des paparazzis
et pas paris tout ce qu'ils y vont avec
leur portable pour filmer pour regarder
ce qui se passe pour qu'ils restent soit
vers la frontière polonaise ou qu'ils
rentrent à l'intérieur et youtuber aussi
ils connaissent pas ils ont pas le
danger j'ai juste faire du buzz
directement c'est ce qu'ils veulent en
vain mais sur un buzz sur la misère des
gens c'est pas la peine c'est pas du
tout la peine j'ai pris quelques photos
j'ai pris quelques vidéos on m'a demandé
j'ai refusé de les donner d'accord donc
on m'a demandé des contacts j'ai refusé
aussi il ya des chose d'autre que j'ai
vu que je peux pas trop forcément parler
c'est quoi vous pouvez me dire je peux
pas trop en parler mais je les camarades
qui sont encore sa place et j'ai des
camarades et par rapport à quoi par
rapport à pas mal de choses par rapport
à aux armements par rapport que je peux
pas parler parce que justement un gilet
propres camarades qui sont sur place
d'accord lors de questions que
parce que je passe à la télé tout
respect qu'un truc banquiers puissent
l'arabe et malheur vous mettiez en
danger la vie de deux camarades avouent
qu'ils sont qui sont là bas vous avez
bien raison aujourd'hui vous avez peur
pour vos camarades qui sont là vous vous
leur dites pas de revenir
peur pour eux non parce que ce que ceux
qui sont là bas que je connais je sais
que sont professionnels je sais qu'ils
ont des années derrière eux
je sais qu'ils vont faire ce qui est
bien pour polyxène quand même mais après
d'autres que je sais qu'ils sont partis
là bas il faut vite qu'ils reviennent
avant que justement
savoir fasse mal à la tête mathieu de
surtout sur des partis également
volontaires français pour tous en
ukraine vous êtes parti pour faire de
l'humanitaire pour aider les réfugiés
quand vous entendez le témoignage de
fabrice qu'est ce que vous dites est
d'accord avec lui je suis complètement
d'accord avec lui maintenant comme je
dis là quand je suis venu
la dernière fois c'est pas un jeu bien
sûr ces pages nous avec avec un très bon
ami et après l'émission on a pu monter
en fait un
convoi et partir là bas mais partir là
bas avant faut savoir que moi j'ai des
contacts sur place aujourd'hui donc
quiconque me dit mathieu je vais t'aider
à amener un véhicule sur place
j'ai les contacts pour l'emmener il
pourra dormir sur place sans aucun
problème est rentré tout en sécurité le
gros problème qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'eau angie les
angels ne passe pas la frontière on y
retrouve on y arrivait sur sur le vivent
vous en voyez le genre voyez les photos
à votre équipe il n'y a pas deux ong il
n'y a rien du tout on se retrouve on se
retrouve nez à nez avec avec un une
tuerie de masse c'est ça avec une tuerie
de masse on a eu la chance d'avoir
des gens qui sont dans la résistance qui
nous ont permis de voir certaines choses
et ils ont voulu nous faire passer un
message un message clair c'est des
besoins qu'ils ont ils n'ont pas besoin
d'eux ils ont pas besoin d'être
d'aliments clairement ils n'ont pas
besoin de manger ils ont ce qu'il faut
pour manger ils ont besoin qu'on ait de
leurs enfants parce que c'est des bbc
des petites filles et petits garçons qui
ont été mis dans le train et leurs
parents sont restés sur place il se
retrouve tout seul avec même pas là on a
vu des vues des images avec des valises
les trois quarts ils ont en face de la
gare de lviv c'est un camp de réfugiés
ils dorment dans la gare la nuit le jour
et ce en dehors il se réchauffe avec des
tonneaux de bois des tonneaux en métal
avec le bois dedans il se réchauffe
comme ça et aujourd'hui leurs besoins il
est très clair c'est un soutien déjà
moral ils ont beaucoup besoin de soutien
moral c'est l'heure
c'est leur leitmotiv on va dire si je
peux utiliser ce mot là c'est clair on
ça et aujourd'hui avec mon ami david on
a fait on a fait le travail avec nos
deniers personnels on a chargé un camion
de 17 mètres cubes dans l'étaler sur
place on a livré sur le centre de brive
le centre humanitaire de lviv ce étaient
dispatchés après et on comprend pas
pourquoi
des ong
qui sont richissimes
ne vont pas alors excusez moi
l'expression porter leurs coûts et
traverser la frontière et elle est
vraiment les aider à lviv aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas y'a pas il n'y a pas même les
polonais font un boulot magnifique à la
frontière ils vont chercher les femmes
et les enfants qui se sont peut-être
pris 40 50 km dans le froid puisqu'il
faut fait moins 10 avec un vent du
diable ils vont les chercher à la
frontière leurs valises et les emmène au
chaud qui font les papiers après c'est
ce qui se passe là-bas donc c'est un
désastre humanitaire
nous on va repartir d'ici une dizaine de
jours elle est repartie en vous dès
qu'on est rechargé et qu'on a repris
la liste que l'on nous a donné on va
leur fournir donc on a besoin on n'a pas
besoin d'argent c'est pas l'argent
problème c'est les médicaments
les premiers secours les vêtements
chauds l'alimentation pour enfants et
bébés
pour pouvoir les soutenir et elle est
vraiment les aider aujourd'hui le risque
qu'il est c'est sûr que c'est une zone
de conflit mais il est très limité quand
même parce que quand on s'approche de la
frontière
je pense pas que les russes on vraiment
envie d'aller avoir un problème de tir
ça vient de taper l'otan n'assure donc
ils ont fait une base militaire ils ont
fait un aéroport militaire je pense que
ça va s'arrêter là ils vont faire
quelque chose histoire de dire on est
toujours dont on est toujours présent
fait attention mais ils ont beaucoup à
faire de l'autre côté aujourd'hui la
résistance ukrainienne elle en est où
enfin il est complètement formés mais ça
c'est à dire que là les russes ont pas
encore pris voilà ici c'est ça ça
pendant corps voilà c'est
les ukrainiens se bat alors il se bat
avec la rage dans leur pays il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui ils veulent pas
partir de chez eux les femmes et enfants
qui ont réussi à quitter le pays c'est
un peu des papas qui les ont pris tu
sors je me desbiens va protéger mes
gosses ça brille comme ça que ça se
passe aujourd'hui s king chance que
l'ukraine s'en sort il ya une chose qui
s'en sort toi oui vraiment sans que ça
c'est une soudure positif il y aura une
chose qui s'en sortent ouais il ya la
résistance mais pareil il faut qu'il y
ait des volontés les moteurs qui porte
la bafoue qui reste professionnel
d'accord c'est s'il ya des gamins qu'ils
y vont avec les les bateaux dans les
roues à l'armée ukrainienne et surtout
dans les rangs ap à savoir faire quoi
que ce soit ça y est ça marchera pas
assaillir après vous avez un collègue
vous l'avez dit un instant et qui vous
êtes parti qui malheureusement
il réussit sa vie là bas c'est un
professionnel c'est un professionnel
quand même il avait quand même fait
sionnel voile alors là quand même fait
but en huit ans de légion mi-temps lyon
et voit l'arrivée le drame l'arrivée il
avait rien dans les mains il ya le
bombardement qui est arrivé au même
moment et puis là toute façon
aujourd'hui soit là c'est les gens qui
veulent s'engager dans la légion enfin
c'est c'est leur problème moi c'est
clair que je les retiendraient coûte que
coûte maintenant il ya une aide
humanitaire il ya une grosse aide
humanitaire à leur fournir il faut avoir
le cran de passer la frontière parce que
faut savoir qu'avec la loi martiale les
chauffeurs ukrainiens n'ont pas le droit
de sortir donc là on a appris ce matin
il ya un décret qui a été fait par le
président ils ont le droit et c'est à
prendre avec des parenthèses j'ai pas vu
le décret de sortir et prendre une
remorque de semis pour l'emmener dans le
pays mais on se retrouve avec des
kilomètres de camions à la frontière
polonaise qui ne peuvent pas rentrer
parce que les chauffeurs veulent pas
prendre le risque d'y aller les camions
sont plus assurés parce que c'est une
zone de guerre
donc on peut pas les laisser comme ça il
faut aujourd'hui
grâce à plusieurs personnes on a réussi
à faire un premier voyage
mission réussie on leur a amené ce qu'il
leur fallait ils nous ont montré la
détresse critiques qu'ils avaient donc
on a eu la chance de la chance on est
allé on est allé dans une école qui
était complètement transformée en centre
de réfugiés pour enfants et femmes on a
eu une alerte une alerte aux
bombardements la vidéo on va là on peut
la mettre sous pli la vidéo merci
d'en melville dans une dans une école
qui a été transformée en centre de
réfugiés de guerre et on est sous une
alerte de paroisse redemande deux
petites filles qui ont 10 et 11 ans qui
sont là qui ceux qui se protègent durant
la phase
dallaire commence ma redevance voilà
deux
voilà le refuge ce qui était mis en
place par par des bénévoles de des
bénévoles ukrainien d'une école on va
essayer de faire ce moment venu aider
ces gens qui aujourd'hui sont
en train de subir un génocide c'est
incroyable ce qu'on voit les images là
vraiment des matches comme ça c'est fou
ce que vous avez ramené mathieu fabrique
le sens très très très abattu et c'est
normal puisqu'il a perdu vous dit s'il
rejoignait de ses amis de ses collègues
qui étaient partis avec lui
vraiment mathieu c'est vous allez
repartir faites attention à l'eau on
fera attention aujourd'hui on a ce qu'il
faut pour être en sécurité la grâce à la
recontacte que j'ai sur place et le
travail le travail sera fait mais je
tiens vraiment on a besoin on a besoin
de deux personnes qui prennent un peu
leurs cran pour pas dire mais leurs
couilles d'aller là bas est vraiment de
traverser cette frontière est juste à la
frontière ukrainienne il ya déjà de quoi
aider et il ya des chauffeurs qui sont
capables d'amener au cas où les
marchandises des différentes
marchandises à lviv pour le moment le
vivent un risque absolument rien encore
jamais prendre le risque d'aller dessus
ils vont assurer voilà et nous
aujourd'hui
la démarche avait été faite par nos
deniers on a mis un coup de pied dans la
dans la motte et je remercie t pmp
d'avoir fait un merci premier geste
c'est ce qui nous a permis de lancer et
j'ai plein des remerciements à faire
j'en oublierais des milliers vous voulez
revenir à faire les mets en garde
on a fait en a fait le j'espère qu'on a
fait notre maximum aujourd'hui l'équipe
les équipes qui sont sur place
c'est la croix-rouge ukrainienne c'est
la croix de malte ukrainienne et rien
d'autre donc si on peut les aider ne
serait-ce que avec un minimum de choses
qui passent la frontière il faut juste
c'est pas le fait 300 m elle fait 300
mètres c'est 300 m on la passe on a ce
qu'il faut pour la passer et on a réussi
la mission même si on va pas sauver 44
millions on en est bien conscient mais
si on arrive déjà alors amené notre
soutien alors amené ce qu'ils ont besoin
parce que médicamenteux médicalement
parlant c'est énorme et militairement
parlant c'est énorme aussi merci mais
juste je tenais juste à remercier je
sais bien le à remercier stock shots
voiron yann d'identity commerce n'est
identique communication mousse de paris
texte qui ne fournit beaucoup de
vêtements chauds pour les enfants julien
polat le maire de voiron et corinne
milliers sa béquille a permis aussi de
récupérer des choses qui n'allaient pas
partir et qu'il est arrêté à la
frontière merci mathieu sergei on y perd
en retard est ce que tu peux revenir
demain pour nous parler de validation il
ya aucun problème non mais vraiment
d'idée que j'ai aucune envie de parler
de poutine actuellement quand va
tranquillement votre avis que les
témoignages était très proche mais c'est
à côté merci merci merci merci merci
downs merci merci à vous de mercy
mathieu fabrique merci à tous tim tout
de suite sur ces vides